it all just got out of it might there
not be some things right there then your
scientific beliefs can't explain
my name is Matt I'm 41 years old I'm a
pastor I'm a okay
40 40 years old I have that mean Easter
ladies Church
I'm Andrew I'm 42 and I'm a chemist I'm
Jess I'm 36 and I'm a volcanologist I'm
Don I'm 64
I'm a paleontologist and geologist I'm
Amy I'm 53 and I'm a rabbi
[Music]
this is literally my greatest fear that
I'd be all alone in the circle I believe
that this world was created I've placed
my faith in a God that is infinitely
creative in what he's made he then
deserves my worship and my affection
seriously last night I was talking about
wife I was like what if there's a
question that I'm just like just stay
where you are like I don't know the big
problem is that means they start talking
with creator and I babble creationism
most my entire career as an evolutionary
biologists and paleontologists it brings
in a whole category of things that
violate my rules as a scientist as well
and when I step back from that
especially when I step back from where I
started as a religious person when I was
younger I look at this and I say you
know if anything what we see now about
the universe shows how poorly designed
it is now sloppy it is and how painful
it is and all these things which don't
speak to a very benevolent creator
because if anything it makes him look
bad I don't believe in a supernatural
God I'm a reconstructionist Jew for me I
don't rely on a supernatural creator in
order to remain astounded at the beauty
of this world that's sloppy
it's the world right it's the world
we're sloppy the world is sloppy but
it's also incredibly magical and and and
worthy of awe and and respect and that
it's here is amazing that we're here is
amazing and I want to live in
relationship to that amazement
I never looked to science to go like is
murder right or wrong I look to science
to say how many murders were committed
last week you know that that's what I
want to know and then say is there a
trend what is the cause of these murders
below and then we use you know we use
different tools I guess is the best way
of putting it to to assess whether or
not we should be murdering people where
did where do those morals come from I
think they're innate in humans all
societies have had certain things that
agree on a Makar that's a religious
background and so on we don't require a
deity or any kind of religion to give us
those things and we come with them as
part of our species and for me it's not
so much that science can answer more
questions but science certainly can
guide us in a lot of ways especially
when moral questions in conflict with
realities we've now learned it
I've got serious gaps in my faith that
require a supernatural answer I mean I
can't I can't understand and fathom the
complexities of the universe all on my
own I'm a Christian I had a church
service someone had a hurt shoulder and
they said my shoulder really hurts so
you pray for my shoulder to get better
I'll be honest with you I have about 5%
faith that that's gonna work out but I
prayed for him I put my hand on his
shoulder and I said you know I want this
shoulder to get healed in Jesus name and
I walked away thinking oh I'm no another
disappointed person who didn't get
healed today well the next morning that
person called me and said you wouldn't
believe it my shoulder feels a 100
percent better I still don't have a good
answer to that but I just know every
time I get an answer or an opportunity
to extra my exercise my faith in a
supernatural way I want to take that
opportunity because I just don't know
what the answer might be
it could be something terrific I totally
agree with you I liked you it's when you
say 5% I pretty much feel the same way
yeah but in my hometown in Japan like we
have this kind of service to instead of
consultive spirits in the line when we
chant or like out you know an hour half
an hour maybe then everybody feels a
whole I feel so peaceful but then can
quite explain it like logically and
that's the stuff that's it's efficient
in that situation science is all about
understanding what we can understand and
the science you're pretty much not
allowed to even consider the
supernatural because it's beyond
testable hypothesis it's beyond anything
that you can evaluate in any what we
might call an objective manner we are
comfortable with the idea that we do not
know something and we say we do not know
something and that was some day we might
find the answer we may not there's a lot
out there that we can't explain it has
absolutely nothing to do with my beliefs
I was raised Catholic and I'm just as
confused now as I was then about what's
really going on you know there there is
a small amount of stuff we can explain I
don't need to have a belief about it I
don't even need to go beyond that
just just to decide that it's
magnificent and terrifying all at the
same time and just kind of leave it at
that
so I think your your answer to the
question would have been yes I mean
because I think you might agree that
there's stuff that you can't even know
to test yet
so how maybe there's something beyond
scientific theory and proof that we
don't even know yet and I'm not saying
God okay
might there not be something so right
there your scientific beliefs can't
explain that's right certainly but and
also in my philosophy I don't see any
point in putting any kind of
supernatural label on it as an
explanation it's just not solving the
problem
I'm so glad you're with me because I
didn't want it to here all by myself I
mean I just see purpose for our lives
that extends beyond the here and now
that there is an eternity that God wants
to have with us his love for us is so
deep that it desires to have a continued
relationship with us as as far as time
goes on because I live in Long Beach I
go down to the beach and I see the waves
of the ocean at the beach they they come
ashore and leave we compare that to life
we take different shapes in different
forms
and the length of the way we have no
idea you'll show up in different
locations which you have no control the
idea that we this this momentary shape
that we have this this life and trying
to preserve it you know and then we're
kind of missing the whole point that we
are actually that greater ocean in my
limited capacity as a individual human
like in this form and this shape I have
no idea how could I possibly have any
idea about what that being ocean is
gonna mean or be and so I know that I
will continue to be part of the universe
but not as me not as this I would agree
with that I mean I see no evidence from
anything that I can observe or anything
that that goes on that it's more than
just wishful thinking that humans in
some form are gonna exist in some
afterlife or they're recognizable and
their identities carry on when I was a
kid I asked my dad mm-hmm if our pets
would be waiting for us in heaven when
we died and my dad said no and I was
shocked and I was like why would there
not be pets in heaven and my dad's like
well there are animals and I'm like why
not my animals and he's like well
they're just like a generic cat and a
generic dog and I went wait what and so
at that point that's when I started to
question like wait a minute what happens
next and and yeah I'm kind of you know
with a lot of you guys here I'm just
saying that look you know it wouldn't it
be great if we could go on and on and on
but I think because we don't see any
evidence for it I have to be in the camp
of well we get this one shot make the
most of it do the best
you can and then when it's done you know
don't have any regrets you know live
with doing as much as you could that is
good so that you will live on in the
memories of those who stay behind I'm so
sorry your dad told you your dogs not
going to heaven what what a crushing
thing to hear the child you know all
good dogs go to heaven
it must be true like some days I'm like
totally Zen I'm totally like solely
there like it's okay it's all one and I
will just not exist I'm usually not as
afraid of death as I am of dying like I
mean I'm afraid of dying because I've
seen some really bad dying I'm very
afraid of pain and a you know the
process of dying I lost both my parents
from counselors side witness the boss
process my mom died over 30 years ago
and it was it was painful to witnessed
that part I mean my mom kind of has
health deteriorate my dad I went through
the same process but then he was runs
writing letters as it just really
coincides with some Buddhist teachings
that I'm having a wonderful day and
really grateful for everybody who
support us we have a saying that every
day is as you say the greatest day I can
see that you know intellectual I can
understand it intellectually but I just
wasn't sure if I could I could feel if I
I would be able to say something like
that if I'm put in the situation
[Music]
and I'm such a skeptic and that includes
questioning my own my own beliefs
especially if I form a hypothesis and
I'm working on an experiment I mean you
always kind of want it to go a certain
way and you have to do your best to
remove that that bias and then some a
lot of times if you're in research just
doesn't work one of the things I tell
students because I work with students a
lot with my nonprofit organization and I
tell them you know as they're journeying
into becoming scientists and they come
from all sorts of different backgrounds
and I just say look don't ever work with
anyone who's afraid to admit that they
don't know something or that they're
wrong like those are really important
qualities whether it's in science or any
aspect of life though the whole fund and
being a scientist is trying to break
things and I actually wanted to start a
journal of scientific mistakes so that
we could share with each other what went
wrong because too often we only talk
about the successes and I think it's
very valuable to also know what failure
is and what it teaches us the
questioning is that such a healthy thing
I always think it's a healthier thing so
whenever I see younger man asks a priest
like yeah go ahead and question question
me a question what you do and then be
okay and you need to understand
understand intellectually but at the
same time I want to understand there are
things that's beyond this intellectual
understanding so that's an
unrecognizable part of understand that
comes only through experience
nice to meet you thank you good to meet
you hey guys this is John I'm Kendra
thank you so much for watching this
episode of middle ground make sure to
let us know what you think in the
comments below and as always please be
sure to click subscribe and watch more
of our stuff we'll see you next time